c'était une date clé dans la sphère de
julie qui accuse une vingtaine de
pompiers de l'avoir violée à partir de
l'âge de 13 ans son pourvoi en cassation
était examinée aujourd'hui en jeu la
requalification en atteinte sexuelle en
2019 par le tribunal de versailles alors
que les pompiers étaient initialement
poursuivis pour viol
et bien finalement l'avocate générale a
conseillé de casser l'arrêt de
versailles ce qui donnerait ou partie
raison à julie je vous propose d'écouter
l'avocat des pompiers concernés et
l'avocate de la jeune fille mes clients
ne doivent pas être regardés comme des
personnes qui aujourd'hui sortirait
indemne de la situation je les dis et je
le rappelle mes clientes ont renvoyé
devant le tribunal correctionnel pour
des atteintes sexuelles
cela n'est pas anodin et aujourd'hui
venir remettre en cause une
qualification pour faire valoir pour
prétendre qu'il y aurait impunité de mes
clients est largement contestable faut
évidemment renvoyé pour une grande
remise à plat ce dossier devant la
chambre de l'instruction qu'il faut
évidemment avoir une autre méthodologie
de compréhension de la d2
de la définition du viol en ce qu'on
vient demander en réalité c'est ce qui
est actuellement dans les débats actuels
c'est de venir encadrer un peu plus par
l'interprétation de la cour de cassation
dont c'est le rôle de venir contrôler le
droit et de donner une méthodologie aux
juridictions qui sont en dessous d'elle
pour faire bonne application application
cohérente de la norme ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui parce qu on est
évidemment dans une société où seuls 1%
des victimes de viols obtiennent justice
il y a plus de dix ans pompiers étaient
intervenus pour julie une jeune fille
déprécie fragile de 13 ans ils s'étaient
revus et les relations sexuelles
s'étaient enchaînés dégénérant en
pratique de groupe sur des capots de
voitures dans des parkings et même dans
l'hôpital psychiatrique dans lequel
julie était traitée alors l'avocat de la
jeune fille a interpellé la cour
accomplir des actes pornographiques à la
demande des adultes n'est pas le
consentement
cette fameuse notion de consentement qui
sera prochainement débattu à l'assemblée
en tout cas cette affaire en tout point
sordide à mobiliser les citoyens
ils sont venus hier soutenir julie et sa
mère et encore ce matin un regroupement
de féministes a été rapidement dispersée
par les forces de l'ordre
nous avons avant cela interviewé claire
charlès présidente des effrontées les
gens soient bien
en effet que c'est violent qu'une gamine
de 13 ans ils peuvent être consentante
que bien sûr que ça on sent les éléments
tels que la contrainte sont là avec des
pompiers qui avaient 20 ans qui était en
situation d'autorité sur une jeune fille
qui est qui qui prenait des médicaments
qui était pas bien qui était qui n'était
pas en état de consentir donc oui c'est
là que je vous dis qu'il ya un gouffre
en fait entre l'évolution de la société
et le côté archaïque des institutions
dans lesquelles il faut vraiment mettre
un grand coup pour que pour que pour ça
ça change quoi et dans cette affaire qui
dure depuis plus de dix ans le délibéré
concernant le pourvoi en cassation sera
rendu le 17 mars